[Music]
on this Sunday night we're breaking news
a sports legend is killed Kobe Bryant
dies in a chopper crash Kobe going to
the cup for 30,000 he's got it
a look back at his career that went
beyond basketball new confirmed cases of
coronavirus it would not be unexpected
that there would be more cases the rush
to track down Canadians with the
potentially deadly disease plus a
Canadian mother and daughter killed on
the ill-fated Ukrainian flight are laid
to rest and remembering a schvitz
my feelings really never change it's a
place of horrific event 75 years since
the liberation of the Nazi death camp
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us a legend in the world of basketball
has died Kobe Bryant was killed in a
helicopter crash in California his 13
year old daughter was among the nine
victims there were no survivors
Bryant spent his 20-year career entirely
with the Los Angeles Lakers four years
ago he retired and at the time he was
the third leading scorer in the NBA
Erik Sorensen has looked back at an
athlete who was considered one of the
best basketball players of all time the
shocking news spread quickly a
helicopter crash in the hills of Los
Angeles County killed nine people
including one of the legends of
basketball Kobe Bryant it was reportedly
Bryant's own private helicopter and that
one of those killed was his daughter
Gianna a budding basketball player
herself Bryant was married and father of
four daughters there were no survivors
we have a manifest indicates that there
was nine people onboard the aircraft the
pilot was eight individuals a true
global ambassador for the sport of
basketball at the Toronto Raptors game
in San Antonio today there was an
immediate tribute to Bryant
Kobe Bryant was one of the greatest
scorers in the game he was third
all-time until just yesterday when
LeBron James passed his 33600 43 points
LeBron acknowledged Kobe his fellow LA
Lakers legend with written notes on his
shoes yesterday because Kobe like LeBron
was one of the few players to make the
leap from high school to the NBA and go
on to an historic career he was going to
be absolutely fantastic tributes have
poured in for one of basketballs greats
former President Barack Obama wrote Kobe
was a legend on the court and just
getting started in what would have been
just as meaningful a second act to lose
Gianna is even more heartbreaking to us
as parents
he was the standard for 20 years of
maybe 15 years or so of what a champion
was known as the Black Mamba bryant won
five NBA championships was the league
MVP an Olympic gold medalist and an
all-star 18 times in a 20-year career
all with the Lakers those times when you
don't feel like working you're too tired
you don't want to push yourself but you
do it anyway that is action
the dream that's the dream it's not the
destination it's the journey he was one
of the first superstars who broke
through in China as a symbol of the game
that helped launch the NBA into the
global sports enterprise it is today an
incredibly you know brilliant man and
incredibly passionate about you know our
game just hours before he died
Bryant sent a poignant congratulations
to LeBron James as James passed his
career scoring mark Bryan tweeted
continuing to move the game forward King
James and Kobe Bryant was also moving
the game forward and he had so much time
left to do so he was only 41 years old
and he was on the verge of being voted
into the Basketball Hall of Fame Robin
Eric you followed many basketball
careers is there a Bryant moment that
stands out for you I think it's it's the
81 points he scored one time that's an
unheard of number to score in one game
81 points and a year after that I was
doing a feature on Steve Nash and I was
asking some Americans about what do they
think about him when winning the most
valuable player award Steve Nash and one
of them would have none of it
he just said no should be number 81 and
by number 81 he meant the man who had
scored 81 points Kobe Bryant who really
had that kind of impact on people just
the way he played the game what a great
story thanks very much Eric now to
Canada's first presumptive case of
coronavirus we're learning the man had
signs of the disease while on the plane
back to Toronto that has health care
workers scrambling to track down anyone
who may have been in close proximity to
him as Jamie Morocco reports the patient
in question did not report his symptoms
when he landed at Pearson Airport as
Canadian passengers continued to take
precautions when flying to China medical
experts are now warning some returning
travelers may have been exposed to the
corona virus based on the latest
information the patient had symptoms on
the plane that man in his fifties
remains in stable condition in a Toronto
hospital after returning on China
Southern Airlines flight seesee 300
Wednesday in a plane contact tracing
perspective we're looking at 2 meter
radius there were
passengers within that two meter radius
they will be contacted no matter where
they are in Canada when asked if the
patient went through Pearson
International Airport's advanced
screening officials said yes but could
not confirm if he reported his symptoms
to border agents when he arrived on
January 22nd instead the Minister of
Health praised the man for contacting
911
on January 23rd more than 24 hours later
the patient when he became ill more ill
that he knew that he realized he needed
medical support in fact followed all of
the information provided at the airport
and well officials say the risk to the
public is low the scenario has some
concern the screening system has cracks
this global health expert disagrees
these things do take time but in this
case public health officials acted
actually very quickly in Canada it's
actually a very good news from a public
health system perspective meantime the
patient will remain under close watch
we'll definitely be continuing to
maintain the same precautions and
observation until we can be confident
that there is enough improvement and
that the patient is no longer at risk of
transmitting to anyone else this is our
health care system braces for the next
confirmed case though we beam all cases
imported into Canada in the near term
given global travel passes an increased
inevitability as Lunar New Year holiday
revelers return home Jamie Muro Kirk
Global News Toronto health officials in
China say the virus has entered a more
serious and complex period and the
numbers reflect that there are now
nearly 2,000 confirmed cases in the
country the death toll has also jumped
50 more deaths reported since yesterday
bringing the total to 56 Hong Kong which
was badly hit by the SARS virus in 2003
has now barred residents of whom a
province where the virus was first
detected from entering the city until
further notice the US government is
reporting its fifth case of the corona
virus a person from Orange County
California the complication of this
virus is that it takes days before there
are any symptoms so people could be
exposed to it and not know it that's
prompted extra health measures around
the
old Jennifer Johnson continues our
coverage US officials are not preparing
to evacuate all diplomats their families
and other American citizens over a
thousand people at a Wuhan China the
epicenter for the outbreak of a new
corona virus it's a process that could
require several trips and planes we're
not entirely sure George Goodwin an
American teacher in Wuhan is nervously
waiting to see what will happen we know
for example the US consulate was told to
evacuate but they haven't been able to
and that said a lot of us on edge there
are now at least five confirmed cases of
the corona virus in the u.s. states that
include Arizona California Washington
and Illinois she was infected in so she
starts to develop symptoms three to four
days after getting back doctor's
advising people to take precautions
because the incubation period for this
new viral illness is so long wash your
hands frequently if you can if you can't
try to use the alcohol stay away from
crowded places with are a lot of people
that are sneezing and coughing and just
do general healthy measures the French
government also held an emergency
meeting and now plans to airlift its
citizens out of Wuhan back to France
the virus is being reported in over 10
countries precautions are being taken
around the world this person escorted
off a plane in Baltimore surgical maps
are selling out parks including
Disneyland Hong Kong are being closed as
the virus spreads I nice New Year
celebrations have also been canceled
from a parade in Paris to celebrations
in Colorado there are people coming from
China so we want to make sure that
people are free of concerns of spreading
of the disease millions of people around
the globe taking no risks as this deadly
virus and fears of contracting it
continue to spread
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
breaking news tonight out of Iraq five
rockets have been fired in the Green
Zone in Baghdad and there are reports
the US Embassy has taken a direct hit
the Green Zone is in the center of the
city and
to government buildings and
international embassies Iraqi officials
say there are no injuries so far no one
has claimed responsibility but there has
been tension between Iran and the US
after onstop general was killed in a US
drone strike in Baghdad earlier this
month the downing of the Ukrainian
airliner was a casualty of that tense
relationship today the family of a
mother and daughter killed in that
tragedy is finally able to say goodbye a
battle with the Iranian government
delayed the return of their remains to
Canada and today a community came
together for the funeral globals Camille
caramely reports a heartbreaking eulogy
from a man who lost his daughter and
granddaughter the bodies of a 37 year
old Sahar hajdu and her daughter
eight-year-old Elsa jdd lay in caskets
in front of him and tears flowing freely
but underneath it all some relief there
remains finally returned home after a
battle with the Iranian government which
wanted the mother and daughter buried in
Iran with the remains finally home those
who knew them trying to find some peace
we lost the part of the family the
mosque completely packed with mourners
we had people from different religions
here we had people from different faiths
from different cultures we saw that
people were praying in different ways
our heart is broken not just our
families everyone in Ontario both mother
and daughter attended this mosque
regularly an integral part of the
community which is why people here say
they'll be missed so deeply I miss them
and this party will miss them because
they was still active so lovely so kind
Sahar was an experienced broadcaster on
an english-language show in Iran she
also ran a program at the YWCA in the
Greater Toronto Area to help settle
immigrant and refugee women in Canada
the grief was too heavy for Sahar's
father her friends now trying to move on
with this in mind hug your family
members your friends a little bit harder
just know that we're blessed to be in
this country and we hope that it never
happens again
Camila chromoly global news Markham
Ontario in Mali all Canadian military
personnel are safe tonight after a
deadly attack at an army camp in the
central part of the country 20 of Mali
security forces were killed during the
pre-dawn attack no one has claimed
responsibility but terrorist groups with
links to al-qaeda and the so-called
Islamic state do operate in the area
Canada wrapped up its peacekeeping
mission in Mali in September but 10
members of the Canadian Armed Forces
remain in the country Canadian police
officers are still deployed with the UN
mission they're expected to remain in
Mali until next year rescue teams in
Turkey are working against the clock to
find more survivors after Friday's
earthquake a two-year-old girl and her
mother were rescued from a collapsed
building today they had been trapped for
28 hours after the magnitude 6.8
earthquake hit the death toll has
climbed to at least 38 people more than
1,600 are injured coming up what the
world saw when El schvitz was finally
liberated 75 years ago
Holocaust survivors have made a solemn
journey to poland monday marks 75 years
since the Nazi concentration camp
Auschwitz was liberated an estimated 1.1
million Jewish people were sent to the
camp between 1940 and 1945 90% of them
were murdered there when Soviet soldiers
liberated Auschwitz on January 27th 1945
there were still 7,000 people there
tonight we have the story of one
Canadian who survived the war here's
Heather York's West
this isn't Joseph got to incres first
trip to Poland
he's called Canada home since the 1960s
but it was in Poland back in 1942
Regatta anchors a story began it was
right in the middle of World War two my
mother had false ID my dad by that time
was already in concentration camp car
tinker likely would not have survived
had it not been for the heroism of a
young Catholic couple who risking death
agreed to take a Jewish baby in as their
own God anchors parents survived the war
his mother found refuge in the Polish
underground but nearly every other
Jewish person in their village was
rounded up by the Nazis it was made what
they call you Dan Frei which was free of
Jews so at that time they either went to
the aircraft factory that was nearby to
the forest and executed or to Auschwitz
though he'll never know for sure got
Dacre suspects many of his relatives
grandparents cousins uncles and aunts
died at the Nazi death camp among the
estimated 1.1 million Jews murdered here
75 years later the number of survivors
are dwindling but those who are able to
have returned to Poland
once again they gathered on Saturday
night in crack house Jewish district for
a candle lighting service which is a
really incredibly moving experience
there were I think about 10 or 15
survivors who were present the oldest
one was a hundred years old and the
youngest one I'm told was was about 74
and she was born actually in Auschwitz
13 Canadians will be among the group of
survivors taking part in a somber
ceremony planned for Monday which will
also be attended by Canada's
governor-general some
are they're coming back for the first
time in 75 years
can you imagine Julie Payette says their
courage to return to the sight of so
much pain is humbling an important
reminder of how we all must never forget
it is our duty all of us to remember and
to stand against hatred against racism
against anti-semitism always Heather
your ex West Global News time for a
short break but when global national
returns the big travel worries that
could impact booming tourist numbers
according to the United Nations
international tourism numbers rose for a
tenth straight year in 2019 2020 is
expected to follow suit but as Reggie
Cecchini reports political tensions and
the threat of illnesses including the
corona virus could impact worldwide
tourism in a world full of uncertainty
the secrets and treasures that dot the
planet still peak curiosity and drive
people to spend time and money on travel
according to the United Nations 1.5
billion people traveled out of their
country in 2019 a 4% increase from the
year before and while that is
record-breaking it was the smallest
increase in years we did see economy
slowing down last year it seems some
travelers were packing worries
instead of toiletries the UK for example
the expectations around what would
happen reflects it had what we often
call a wait-and-see attitude both from
consumerism and companies which at the
end of today makes people travel travel
less political and social unrest can
contribute to a slump in international
arrivals but not enough to stall the
industry what you know is really driving
that is essentially the wealth that's
being generated in a lot of developing
economies 20 19 s small rise in tourism
did generate more than 1.8 trillion
dollars in revenues there's all sorts of
supply chain impacts in terms of hotels
in terms of other activities that
tourism dollars generate some countries
have a proven track record when it comes
to tourism Canada was the 17th most
visited country last year with an
expected 21 million visitors France
Spain and the u.s. saw the most
travelers in 2019 history and culture
drawing tourists in along with clever
advertising a lot of these destinations
are now looking at social influencers to
come in and experience their location
and then using that as marketing 2020
tourism numbers are predicted to match
2019 thanks to global events like the
Dubai Expo and Tokyo Olympics but the
year is off to a rough start
economic and health threats are forcing
governments to adapt to the unknown and
plan for the future of travel it's
probably one of the most important
things that there is an acknowledgement
that the sector can actually contribute
to the objectives that a country has in
the walther putting tourism to the test
regi Cecchini Global News up next the
hockey girls from Kyrgyzstan breaking
stereotypes
ice hockey is a much loved sport in
Canada enjoyed by both men and women but
in many parts of the world hockey is
still male-dominated as Radio Free
Europe Stuart Grier tells us more than a
dozen girls from a remote village in
Kyrgyzstan are shattering gender
stereotypes as their country's first
all-female hockey team emerging like
winter warriors from a mud hut dressing
room
these cookies girls are shattering
stereotypes by taking to the ice meat
Kyrgyzstan first all-female hockey team
they've been playing for more than two
years in the northern village of a
thread Noah 16 year old Nora
kenji by Ewa is the team's captain rocks
around both are very good stir through
their physical and fearless plan the
girls quickly earned the respect of
their male rivals they are even cheered
on by their opponents with no other
female teams to play the girls always
have to face off against boys clubs over
the last 20 years hockey in this Central
Asian nation of six million has
gradually taken root there is now a
professional league and more than a
thousand registered a mature male
players but there was nothing for girls
until salamat Abdul Rahman off started
the all-female team for his daughter and
her friends a small TV actor his name in
the vitamin and other Bo formal are
killing the violence to be so cheeky
imitating a copepod Kenda resumed after
the hockey game Nora in kenji by Ava
heads back home
she may be challenging local stereotypes
but off the ice she can't escape from
her domestic duties go class but one
song we did I'm finished cadet cuz they
need a Jewish group you were part of
this this - same tradition mouseout they
did but after her work at home is done
no team can get back to the ring with
lights hung on trees she and the other
girls can chase their hockey dreams well
into the night shouldn't they be our
source didn't get it anyway so then you
should need an illustrated can cause too
much passed on close to the Dominic tip
started playin cause one minute
the bit of meanness the labor Salem but
close down the drain your own girl it
does that Nora would soon be sharing her
knowledge and passion for the game with
growing interest from girls in
neighboring villages there may soon be
enough players for a second female
hockey team in Kyrgyzstan mr. Greer
Radio Free europe/radio Liberty and that
is global national for this Sunday I'm
Robin Gill tonight your Canada is
maligne lake in Jasper National Park
thank you for watching
Donna free zone will be back here
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you
[Music]